bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir les pistes de réforme
sur l'immigration signée Gérald Darmanin
et Olivier du soft à peine publié
l'interview des deux ministres de
l'Intérieur et du travail à suscité un
tollé à droite et à l'extrême droite la
mesure qui fâche le titre de séjour
métier sous tension que propose le
gouvernement pour répondre à la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre régularisation par le
travail ou appel d'air dangereux grand
débat très politique ce soir avec nos
invités dans un instant notre grand
témoin est un haut fonctionnaire
atypique venu de la gauche il était
professeur d'histoire-géo bien avant de
réussir Léna il a été aux avant-postes
de la crise sanitaire pendant 20 mois et
livre un récit personnel passionnant sur
les coulisses du pilotage de la crise du
covid la blessure et le rebond chez
Odile Jacob réflexion sur l'action
publique par gros temps Aurélien
Rousseau l'ancien patron de à l'ARS
Île-de-France et actuel directeur de
cabinet d'Élisabeth borne est avec nous
ce soir enfin nos affranchis pour trois
parties pris j'ai nommées Fanny
guinochet pour l'économie la France
championne des impôts malgré les baisses
annoncées le regard européen de Richard
Verly Lula le nouveau président du
Brésil est-il le meilleur allié de
l'Europe pas forcément on le verra et
puis la mise au point d'Isabelle laffert
sur la guerre ce soir la Crimée
péninsule sous tension voilà pour le
menu c'est parti
[Musique]
être méchant avec les méchants et
gentils avec les gentillesse pourrait
être une phrase dans la bouche d'un
écolier de primaire ce sont les mots de
Gérald Darmanin
on doit aider ceux qui bossent et on
doit être dur avec ceux qui mettent des
axes de délinquance voilà le ministre de
l'Intérieur a dévoilé ce matin les
grandes lignes de son projet de loi sur
l'immigration avec son homologue au
travail durcissement sur les expulsions
d'un côté et maintendue pour les
travailleurs immigrés de l'autre le et
en même temps macronien a-t-il enfin
trouvé sa doctrine sur l'immigration
bonsoir Vincent Ledoux et merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes député renaissance
du Nord c'est la circonscription de
Gérald Darmanin Tourcoing dont vous êtes
le suppléant j'imagine que peut-être
vous l'avez eu aujourd'hui au téléphone
vous nous direz ce qu'il a voulu dire
parce que voilà il y a eu il y a eu les
mots dans la presse et puis après il y a
eu les mots au micro il a beaucoup parlé
bonsoir Pierre-Henri Dumont et bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes député les
républicains du Pas-de-Calais bonsoir
Philippe Balard ravi de vous retrouver
députés rassemblements national de
l'Oise Aurélien tachée député
europécologie les Verts du Val-d'Oise et
membre de la nupette va nous rejoindre
dans un tout petit instant on sera aussi
avec Stéphane Manigold salut grand
restaurateur parisien et et qui
représente lumine pour l'Île-de-France
le Miss c'est l'Union des métiers de
l'industrie de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration qui a bien besoin de
trouver de la main d'oeuvre c'est
dernier mois voilà pour les
présentations qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans
cette interview Stéphane vous allez nous
le dire la mi blackovski si j'ai bien
compris tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
messieurs j'ai bien compris ce soir
alors si j'ai bien compris Myriam le
projet de loi du gouvernement sur
l'immigration il prévoit plus
d'expulsions mais en même temps une
meilleure intégration donc comme le
souligne nos confrères des échos le
gouvernement estime que son projet de
loi il est et qui dit alors ça veut dire
ni trop pas droit ni trop pas gaucher
il est en même temps de droite et de
gauche et en la preuve c'est que voilà
les deux ministres qu'ils défendent
c'est d'un côté donc Gérald Darmanin qui
est ancien porte-parole de Nicolas
Sarkozy à ses côtés Olivier du soft
ancien porte-parole de Marty devry donc
l'équilibre est peut-être pas totalement
respecté dans la mesure où dans
l'interview quand on la lit Darmanin
parle beaucoup plus que l'idée du stop
le journal pose une dizaine de questions
faut attendre la cinquième question
avant que Olivier du soft dis un mot
donc ça pour vous ça signifie que le
projet penche plus à droite qu'à gauche
c'est ce que j'avais cru comprendre en
disant l'interview d'autant que Gérald
Darmanin lui s'appuie pour expliquer
comment ce projet de loi a été réfléchi
sur un rapport qui vient des
républicains au Sénat écrit par Bernard
Noël buffet c'est non du sénateur et
voilà ce que dit ce rapport il dit que
la loi est tellement compliqué
aujourd'hui pour faire expulser les gens
que on arrive même plus à la faire
appliquer donc Gérald Darmanin reprend
les termes du rapport il soutient les
républicains à fond l'écoute
d'autres droits est trop complexes pour
expulser un étranger en situation
irrégulière nous avons jusqu'à 12
recours administratifs et judiciaires 12
recours le projet de loi que nous allons
porter à la demande du Président de la
République c'est divisé par 3 on passera
de 12 à 4 bon alors si les mesures du
rapport les républicains François Noël
buffet sont reprises la droite est
satisfaite mais bien sûr que non ils
sont très mécontents à droite évidemment
parce que à partir il y a de ce coup de
vis que prétendonner d'armanin mais il y
a aussi une autre mesure annoncée par
Olivier du stop qui est l'idée de
accorder un titre de séjour donc de
régulariser des immigrés dès lors que
ils ont effectué des missions des
métiers en tension voilà c'est fameux
métier où on en arrive plus aujourd'hui
à recruter donc ça côté républicain ça
passe pas je ne sais pas si c'est
l'ambiance de campagne électorale pour
désigner le président mais en tout cas
on a dit on ne marche pas ces mots on
écoute on va bien Pradier il faut dire
les choses simplement il s'agit d'une
régularisation automatique et massive
d'un certain nombre de travailleurs qui
aujourd'hui sont dans pays et qui ne
sont pas nationalisés ou qui n'ont pas
la nationalité française pour le dire
plus simplement
en situation régulière et donc derrière
les mots il faut préciser la pensée il
s'agit d'une régularisation massive j'y
suis tout à fait défavorable alors là
plus de disputes entre Pradier
Retailleau et trois candidats ils sont
tous exactement sur les mêmes longueurs
d'onde je vous montre le tweet si vous
voulez de Retailleau finalement la
nouvelle c'est que les républicains sont
tous d'accord et en même temps ils sont
tous d'accord avec qui avec Marine Le
Pen bah oui parce que Marine Le Pen elle
c'est pas fait la même pas eu à écrire
un long tweet mais une seule remarque
suffisait pour rappeler sa position
toute la droite est opposée à ce projet
de loi
est-ce que toute la droite n'est pas
toute la droite à moins qu'on considère
évidemment que le Medef soit noyauté par
les gauchistes et que ce sont des gens
vraiment à gauche non parce que du côté
des patrons on est plutôt favorable à
l'immigration et je reprends route des
yeux qui était au mois de juin sur
France Info il donnait même un conseil
au gouvernement on écoute ce conseil
je dis d'abord au gouvernement que sur
le long terme les pays européens dont la
France vont devoir réfléchir
sérieusement à l'immigration économique
on est une population vieillissante et
donc si on a de moins en moins de jeunes
qui travaillent c'est juste
mathématiques alors ça pose d'autres
problèmes d'intégration à l'immigration
économique ça veut dire en accueillir
davantage bien sûr et la droite qui est
favorable à l'immigration
ça veut dire quoi d'ailleurs droite
gauche aujourd'hui nous prenons le mot
intégration par exemple est-ce que
l'intégration c'est de droite ou est-ce
que l'intégration ces deux gauches parce
que c'est un mot auquel Bernard est très
attaché il a répété cinq fois
intégration dans son interview du monde
là je voulais vous proposer un petit
extrait de ce qu'ils disait mais j'ai
raté mon coche j'ai pas bien donné le
sonore donc je vous répète en gros ce
qu'il disait il voudrait faire passer
des tests de français pour les gens qui
viennent immigrants pour travailler et
si on a pas un niveau de sub français
suffisant on ne peut pas être régularisé
tout ça au nom de l'intégration mais
est-ce que cette droite est-ce que c'est
de gauche je vous laisse en débattre
merci
pour votre regard quotidien du soir
Stéphane Vincent Ledoux franchement
peut-être est de droite et de gauche ça
c'est la signature Macron sur
l'immigration n'empêche que vous n'avez
plus la majorité absolue dans cette
émission donc vous allez avoir besoin
des voix d'autres groupes politiques
c'est pour ça que il est très très
politique ce texte en plus d'être très
important c'est un sujet qui préoccupe
les Français est-ce que vous attendiez à
une telle levée de bouclier à droite et
au rassemblement national sur les
premières mesures annoncées dans le
monde ce matin
a plus rien en ce moment c'est tellement
compliqué tellement complexe moi ce que
je sais c'est que le travail qui a mené
le ministre de l'Intérieur au Sénat a
été plutôt productif jusqu'à présent et
il a réussi à trouver une articulation
intelligente avec les sénateurs de
manière à ce qu'on trouve de la valeur
ajoutée sur un texte et sur un texte
aussi important que celui que l'on
discute ce soir c'est important de
mettre de l'intelligence autour de la
table il y a une mesure qui fâche on va
revenir dans le détail tout à l'heure
mais moi je voudrais comprendre ce titre
de séjour pour métier en tension tout
l'après-midi Gérald Darmanin a répété
que ça n'était qu'une idée ça n'était
pas une mesure dans le projet de loi ça
veut dire quoi une simple idée soumise
au débat ça veut dire que à la fin vous
pouvez renoncer c'est ça je pense que tu
dis qui est une réalité moi j'ai en tête
dans ma circonscriptions faut dire Aaron
qui travaille dans une fromagerie c'est
un Guinéen que j'ai accompagné que j'ai
soutenu et auquel j'ai demandé enfin
j'ai demandé au préfet de pouvoir avoir
un oeil bienveillant sur ces situations
qui n'était pas bonne au départ voilà
bon mais la chef d'entreprise me le
réclamer à corps et à cri voilà j'ai en
tête Augustin à Tourcoing vous voulez le
faire ce titre de séjour ça n'est pas
juste un ballon d'essai parce que pour
politique tout est possible à la
commission d'enquête parlementaire où
j'ai clairement fait des propositions
allant dans ce sens donc c'est une
besoins
vous y prenez très bien Pierre Henri
Dumont on va essayer de sortir de
l'idéologie parce que c'est toujours
voilà très compliqué de parler
ce texte reprend Stéphane Lady toutes
les mesures quasiment du sénateur les
républicains François Noel buffet et
notamment la simplification du maquis
des procédures qui retardent l'exécution
des fameuses qtf les obligations à
quitter le territoire français ça
devrait quand même vous parler un petit
peu mais sur cette mesure en particulier
qui est celle de réduire les voies de
recours pour faciliter les expulsions
réduire les différentes possibilités de
recours on est évidemment pour c'est
nous qui l'avions proposé on l'a proposé
pas simplement dans le rapport du
président de la commission des Lois du
Sénat François-Noël lui fait on l'a
proposé lors de la première loi Asie
l'immigration en 2019 présenté par
Gérard Collomb et qui avait été rejetée
par la majorité à l'époque on avait
proposé j'avais proposé par voie
d'amendement par exemple la délivrance
automatique d'une obligation de quitter
le territoire français à toute demandeur
d'asile qui est débouté de sa demande
cela avait été rejeté par la majorité de
l'époque aujourd'hui ça va revenir dans
le texte de loi moi je prends acte je
prends acte d'une part que la même
majorité ou presque va à voter contre ce
que nous avions se poser au niveau des
républicains hier pour aujourd'hui le
faire et je d'autre part qu'ils ont donc
perdu cinq ans et que c'est 5 ans où on
a vu s'accumuler
s'accumuler qui arrive en plus sur le
territoire français et c'est 50 perdues
sur la dimension très politique de steak
depuis ce matin on voit bien que le
gouvernement essaie de déminer un peu
qui a vraiment une levée de bouclier à
droite parfois même peut-être un peu de
mauvaise foi vous allez me dire si vous
êtes d'accord avec Eric Ciotti candidat
à la présidence des républicains ce qui
n'est pas un peu dans la caricature
quand il dit ça
on n'arrive pas à expulser les personnes
qui subissent une qtf qui sont en
situation irrégulière donc idée géniale
trouver par les deux ministres on va
régulariser des étrangers en situation
irrégulière entrer illégalement sur le
territoire au motif qu'il pourrait
pourvoir des métiers en tension voilà
donc c'est une forme de supercherie pour
aller une nouvelle fois vers une
régularisation
vous êtes d'accord la démarche de
gouvernement mais les métiers en tension
c'est quoi le problème le problème c'est
qu'on a plusieurs centaines de milliers
de Jobs qui sont nos pourvus et on a à
côté de ça plusieurs millions de
Français d'étrangers en situation
régulière déjà présent en France
de l'hypocrisie absolue que ça veut dire
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il y a
des jobs qu'on considère pas assez bien
pour les français pour les étrangers en
situation régulière déjà présent sur le
territoire et que du coup on estime que
pour ces jobs là comme personne n'en
veut on doit faire venir plus de
personne moi je suis désolé je préfère
qu'on ait un meilleur salaire une
meilleure protection sociale qu'on
s'interroge sur l'ubérisation de la
société sur le fait de est-ce que c'est
normal de pouvoir me faire livrer de la
nourriture à 5h du matin par un immigré
clandestin à scooter dans une ville de
grande ville de France je préfère qu'on
m'interroge sur ça plutôt que de dire
bah non au contraire il va faire mieux
plus de personnes le tour de table pour
essayer d'y voir plus clair Philippe
Balard sur le volet expulsion
des clandestins sous le sous le coup
d'occupé F le gouvernement va demander
au préfet je cite là le ministre de leur
pourrir la vie en fait clairement les
prévention des aides sociales des
logements sociaux en les inscrivant et
ça c'est nouveau au fichier des
personnes recherchées de manière à mieux
suivre l'exécution de ces fameuses
occultées là encore pas convaincu
d'abord c'est de la com parce qu'ils
sont déjà au fichier des personnes
recherchées c'est même la fiche e
précisément qui recense tous ceux qui
ont une itef moi il y a des policiers
qui m'ont envoyé leur mode d'emploi en
fait donc ça c'est c'est de après vous
parlez de ces déclarations de Gérald
Darmanin à propos des préfets on va leur
rendre la vie difficile plus le logement
sociaux plus d'allocation familiale mais
vous rendez compte on en est en France
quand même en 2022 c'est à dire que
quelqu'un qui est en situation
irrégulière qui est clandestin qui
devrait être expulsé bénéficie de
logements sociaux d'Allocation
Familiales d'allocations diverses et
variées des Français n'ont pas forcément
accès on marchera la tête alors après
sur les auqqf il faudrait quand même le
mode d'emploi il y a 120000 locuteurs à
l'instant T de prononcer comment vont
faire les forces de l'ordre à peu près
il y a 120 000 policiers 120 000
exécutés 14000 ça fait à peu près
sur quelle base ils vont se pointer chez
les gens mais comme ils sont
clandestagères non c'est pas où ils
habitent ils vont contrôler tout le
monde dans la rue et puis une fois que
allez on va jusqu'au bout de la démarche
ils arrêtent c'est 120000 ils
interpellent garde à vue 120 000
personnes il faut un laisser passer
consulaire après pour les expulser et là
c'est le noeud du problème c'est qu'il y
a pas de volonté politique on l'a vu
avec Emmanuel Macron Elisabeth borne qui
sont allés on va prendre ce pays de
l'Algérie 2021 chiffre du ministère de
l'Intérieur cité par Gérald Darmanin
7500 algériens ont eu une aucutée en
2021 expulsion 22 expulsion 22 et le
bras de fer avec ses pays là c'est à
dire nous on délivre plus aucun visage
vous voulez pas reprendre ce qu'on veut
expulser plus de visa et puis on
t'arrive plus financier qu'il soit privé
qu'il soit public et on va voir
Bruxelles pour qu'il fasse la même chose
Aurélien Tachet je termine le tour de
table dans téléspectateurs on peut voir
un peu situer chacun puis on ira ensuite
sur la mesure particulière qui qui fâche
certains sur sur la régularisation dans
certains dans certains métiers vous avez
quitté vous le parti présidentiel vous
étiez un macroniste de gauche assez mal
à l'aise on s'en souvient vous l'aviez
dit publiquement sur notamment le sujet
de l'immigration il est équilibré ce
texte pour vous non pas du tout
évidemment que non moi j'avais fait un
rapport sur la question de l'accueil et
de l'intégration des des primo arrivants
comme on dit dans ce langage un peu
barbare administrat en gros des
étrangers qui viennent d'arriver sur
notre sol que j'avais remis en 2018 à
Édouard Philippe pour dire tout ce qui
n'allait pas alors effectivement
j'entends monsieur Dumont dire que il
faut accélérer des matérialiser les les
procédures pour le retour mais c'est
tout aussi vrai pour l'accueil votre
collègue buffet d'ailleurs le dire dans
son rapport aussi est-ce que c'est
normal qu'on est toujours c'est file
d'attente on est la 7e puissance du
monde devant les préfectures ça fait
honte à tout le monde les gens
évidemment qui vont rester se disent
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce pays qui
me fait dormir
mais donc on a tout un tas de sujets qui
ne vont pas ce texte n'est absolument
pas équilibré ce texte ne changera pas
grand chose effectivement parce que pour
le coup je suis d'accord avec Monsieur
Balard ce qui vient d'être dit sur le
fichier des étrangers signalés existe
déjà donc tout ça et du blabla tout ça
et simplement de la vous avez pas de
dimension politique mais en Kawa c'est
ça en fait le problème il y a sur
l'immigration c'est très simple il y a
le terrain il y a la politique le
terrain c'est des gens qui travaillent
c'est des gens qui sont là qui parfois
aussi peuvent causer des difficultés ça
peut arriver ils sont ni meilleur ni
moins bon que les autres les étrangers
ils sont comme tout le monde finalement
mais dans la réalité des faits c'est
surtout des gens qui occupent des
emplois difficiles des gens qui ont du
mal à s'intégrer des gens qui ont du mal
et à qui on ne donne pas de papier
pourquoi parce que on veut faire plaisir
à l'électorat de Monsieur Ballard et
Madame Le Pen alors justement monsieur
Darmanin il est coincé là-dedans il y a
un principe de réalité les gens des
organisations économiques lui disent
monsieur il faut régulariser ce n'est
pas sérieux en fait pour la France de
faire ce qu'on fait sur le plan
migratoire mais monsieur Darmanin fait
de la politique et donc il est un petit
peu embêté alors on s'arrête maintenant
sur cette idée faire en sorte que le
travail redevienne une valeur
d'intégration c'est la fameuse mesure
titre de séjour métier en tension va
d'abord entendre les employeurs mais pas
seulement vous allez le voir c'est un
restaurateur il s'appelle Stéphane
machaud il est restaurateur à Paris près
de la gare Saint-Lazare et pour lui
aucun doute les besoins de main d'oeuvre
sont-elles qu'il faut faciliter la
régularisation des travailleurs
étrangers reportages Marco pommier avec
Steven Martin
samba Mara et blanchisseur dans cette
brasserie parisienne d'origine malienne
il travaille dans cet établissement
depuis 2016 aujourd'hui il est en CDI
c'est compliqué ce métier pas compliqué
si à la volonté c'est pas compliqué à la
volonté c'est pas compliqué mais ne
compliqué super
[Musique]
sans papiers samba Mara a débuté ce
travail sous une autre identité la
législation française ne l'autorisez pas
à occuper un emploi après 6 mois de
service Stéphane malchaux le gérant de
cette brasserie l'a aidé dans ses
démarches de régularisation jusqu'à
écrire au sénateur de sa circonscription
quand vous avez un poste vacances et que
vous mettez beaucoup de temps à trouver
un salarié pour le prendre c'est qu'il y
a une problématique d'offre et de
demande il faut élargir l'offre sinon
qu'est-ce qui va se passer
quand vous viendrez manger un jour au
restaurant on vous répondra écoutez
monsieur revenez demain j'ai passé de
personne pour vous servir ça ressemble à
quoi le manque de main d'oeuvre c'est
une réalité dans cette brasserie malgré
les 40 à 50 employés qui se relaient
cuisinier chef de rang plongeur ces
métiers de la restauration n'attire plus
depuis la pandémie alors pour servir les
350 couverts de la journée Stéphane
malchaux n’hésite pas à recruter des
étrangers ils ont
d'incontestables qualité
qu'ils ont avant d'être régularisés et
qu'ils gardent après être régularisé on
a besoin de cette main d'oeuvre elle est
volontaire c'est des gens qui veulent
travailler donc vous donner du travail à
des gens qui veulent travailler dans cet
établissement deux autres salariés sont
en cours de régularisation
voilà donc pour la réalité du terrain
Stéphane maligold merci beaucoup d'avoir
patienté je sais que vous êtes un peu
pressé dites nous lui que vous
représentez ce soir pour l'Île-de-France
et sur la même longueur d'onde que ce
restaurateur
qu'il faut distinguer plusieurs choses
nous déjà on est des chefs d'entreprise
on fait pas politique donc la première
chose c'est que lorsque nous avons un
travailleur que nous découvrons en
situation irrégulière aujourd'hui le
droit nous impose le licencier nous
avons pas d'autres solutions et si
demain cette mesure nous permet pas ce
qui s'est intégré parce qu'il travaille
depuis un an deux ans donc les
entreprises et bien si cette mesure
permet de le régulariser moi je trouve
que c'est une bonne chose maintenant je
note aussi que sur le site de Pôle
Emploi qui est disponible au fond par
n'importe qui et bien vous avez 100
000 emplois 100 000 personnes qui
cherchent du travail sur le site de Pôle
Emploi qui sont demandeurs d'emploi il
faut trouver une solution dans la
restauration c'est 100000 personnes qui
cherchent du travail et ces gens ils
sont disponibles tout de suite il y a
quand même le bâtiment certains travaux
manuels dans l'agriculture la question
de la restauration l'hôtellerie là il y
a moins moins de demandes vous le
reconnaissez vous avez raison il y a 14
il y a 14 719 personnes qui cherchent
dans le bâtiment disponibles en France
donc je crois qu'il faut ici avoir cette
réalité c'est que la réforme du chômage
elle doit changer elle doit conduire à
remettre la valeur travail dans dans
tous les secteurs parce que tous les
secteurs sont en tension et je vous
invite à aller sur le site de Pôle
emploi.fr qui est très bien fait vous
avez accès à la base de données de toute
cette et ceux qui bénéficient de la
solidaire qui est nationale et qui
cherchent du travail donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut c'est juste un dernier point
un dernier point s'il vous plaît je
profite d'être sur la chaîne
parlementaire et d'avoir des députés
vous savez le débats qu'on a là
aujourd'hui si lacrim énergétique rien
n'est fait elle va balayer des TPE et
des PME alors les problèmes qu'on est en
train de voir aujourd'hui si rien n'est
fait si on ne protège pas les
entreprises alors ce sera ce sera des
problèmes de riche et on pourra pas
sur sur les questions de bouclier
tarifaire pour les entreprises sont
insuffisantes derniers mots il y a pas
un peu d'abus quand même de la part des
employeurs qui préfèrent tout simplement
un travailleur sans papier plus
malléable plutôt que d'aller
l'accompagner à la préfecture pour
l'aider à être régularisé et l'assumer
au fond le droit comme je vous l'ai dit
aujourd'hui nous oblige à licencier ce
salarié lorsqu'on découvre c'est des
véritable drame à la fois pour les
collègues de travail parce que ils sont
intégrés dans l'entreprise maintenant si
vous voulez me faire dire à moi qui suis
qui fait partie de la nouvelle
génération d'entrepreneurs dans ces
métiers si vous voulez faire dire que
oui il y a eu des salles comportements
qu'il faut les condamner et que je les
condamne et que l'avenir demain dans le
tourisme c'est certainement pas ce qui
s'est passé avant tournons la page de
l'Ancien Monde créons une nouvelle
histoire ensemble sans division sans
polémique Merci à VOUS Stéphane Manigod
nous avoir accordé en duplex depuis une
gare je crois quelques quelques minutes
allez va sur Ledoux moi j'aimerais
j'aimerais comprendre tous les
employeurs on en a entendu beaucoup chez
nos confrères toute la journée Lydia
énormément de besoins ça urge quand on
entend Geoffroy de monsieur qui dit
voilà c'est un problème de cours moyen
terme il va falloir regarder les choses
en face donner des titres de séjour
pluriels mais avec des mesures
d'intégration de langue française en
contrepartie préciser les choses la
maîtrise du français est un prérequis
oui non ça semble être du bon sens quand
vous voulez vous intégrer dans un pays
vous devez en savoir parler là on passe
à me semble le préalable indispensable
pour moi connaître les codes pour
pouvoir discuter les uns avec les autres
mais je pense que
tous des exemples de personnes qui sont
arrivés avec une maîtrise imparfait de
langue française et qui très vite très
très vite parce qu'ils s'adapte
parfaitement bien à la situation parlent
le français je pense qu'à un moment
donné il faut effectivement contrôler le
niveau toutes les inquiétudes essentiels
en fait ça correspondrait à combien de
personnes régularisées cette mesure on a
ce chiffre de 300 000 emplois non pourvu
alors c'est un flux donc il faut le
prendre avec des pincettes ça veut dire
300000 personnes régularisées du jour au
lendemain oui ou non non il faut d'abord
que ça correspond aux emplois parce que
c'est un préalable
concerné par ces mesures de
régularisation dans les différents
secteurs
soient ensemble c'est la double entrée
en vérité c'est-à-dire qu'on a
effectivement le problème de la
migration qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
régler de manière intelligente et
collective parce que les Français nous
le demandent depuis très longtemps et
deuxièmement il y a le problème des
métiers sous tension moi toutes les
semaines dans ma circonscription j'ai
des restaurateurs qui pleurent parce
qu'ils sont seuls et qui sont exténués
je reprends mon petit Augustin de
Tourcoing jeune sénégalais cuisinier
mais qui trouve tous les emplois du
monde et alors Augustin il est venu
comment il est venu par le dispositif
jeune pro de l'OFI c'est-à-dire qu'il
est venu de manière tout à fait
absolument qu'il est venu de manière
tout à fait régulière et qui est venu
pourquoi parce qu'il avait déjà une
qualification au départ à Dakar et qu'il
vient monter en gamme pour repartir chez
lui après c'est ça on dit toujours une
situation qui n'est pas du tout
accompagner
c'est vrai quand on regarde les chiffres
14000 chauffeurs de bus ont recherchés
dans notre pays mille infirmiers rien
qu'à la PHP c'est pas rien cristiane
Lambert disait ce matin il y a urgence
il y a des tâches agricoles pénibles que
les Français ne veulent pas faire le
Medef pareil en quoi intégré par le
travail c'est pas une bonne idée
coloniale pardon de dire enfin vous
imaginez vous êtes en train de dire que
les Français ne veulent pas le faire
donc du coup on prend des gens qu'on va
pouvoir payer à bas coût pour pouvoir
faire le travail que les Français
veulent pas faire face c'est
profondément
il se passe quoi aujourd'hui il se passe
que en France on a une immigration du
travail si on regarde les chiffres qui
est sous-représenté c'est 13% des
premiers titres de séjour la moyenne de
l'OCDE c'est un tiers à peu près hein
pourquoi parce que en fait c'est
l'immigration familiale et l'immigration
les studiante qui ensuite deviennent des
immigrations de travail donc en fait on
a une population immigrée qui a un
niveau à 40% qui est inférieur ou égal
au brevet des collèges quand la
population globale c'est 20% ces
chiffres ne sort pas nulle part c'est le
rapport que j'ai écrit avec une député
de la majorité lors du précédent mandat
et donc au final il se passe quoi il se
prend il se passe comprendre la
l'immigration familiale et studiantines
pour combler les travaux qui sont pas
occupés par des Français ou des
étrangers qui sont plus qualifiés déjà
présent sur le territoire et tout le
monde s'en satisfait et après on dit
mince faut qu'on les régularise et ben
non ça marche pas comme ça ça veut dire
que il faut sur le banc de la droite
entendre dire que une telle mesure et
Neo coloniale j'avoue ça ça m'a surpris
votre l'augmentation du SMIC il vote
contre toutes les AM opérations sur les
droits sociaux et après il nous explique
qu'il faudrait que les Français se
découvrent une passion pour des métiers
qui n'ont pas forcément envie d'exercer
pardon on va pas légaliser le travail
forcément donc voilà beaucoup plus
difficile il y a des gens qui veulent
d'avoir des personnes qui préfèrent
rester au chômage toucher les
allocations un travail c'est
profondément
mais c'est absolument la réalité des
choses la réalité des choses c'est
plutôt ce que nous habitons plus près de
la réalité en effet plus près de votre
réalité
selon le territoire c'est le député vous
le savez je veux dire à un moment vous
le savez ces métiers là sont difficiles
il y a de moins en moins de jeunes qui
veulent les faire si vous votez avec
nous les augmentations de salaire
peut-être que ça aiderait un tout petit
peu à les motiver
c'est pas c'est pas l'assemblée qui
décide il y a toujours des difficultés
c'est pas une économie administrée c'est
pas l'URSS la possibilité d'encourager
tout ça et en attendant il y a des gens
qui effectivement fuient une situation
qui pourrait plus compliquée quand on
arrive du Sénégal d'ailleurs quand ils
veulent venir en France travailler
s'intégrer quel est le problème si ce
n'est leur prénom leur couleur de peau
leur religion je ne sais quoi mais ça
c'est le problème du rassemblement
il y a quand même un principe de réalité
hein il y a des emplois donc pourvu et
on entend les employeurs ça vous le
reconnaissez comment vous gérez ce
problème il est français travailleur ne
veulent pas occuper ces postes selon
l'adresse il y avait une 360 000 emplois
d'Arès c'est lié au ministère du du
travail rappelons qu'il y a 5 millions
de chômeurs aussi il faut quand même
mettre les deux en parallèle ah bah je
pense que ce sont des métiers qui
doivent avoir une revalorisation
salariale on peut pas couper le débat
non mais c'est pas suffisant c'est pas
parce qu'on a une autre proposition qui
est plus efficace c'est une augmentation
de 10% jusqu'à 3 sem donc 4500 euros
parce que votre proposition n'est pas
pragmatique et c'est pour ça que c'est
tout ça on a non parce que ceux qui sont
juste au-dessus ils vont être avalés et
puis c'est une trappe impressionniste
est-ce que vous y croyez pas les
français pour pour tout le monde pour
les étrangers mais simplement et qu'on
est dans une situation où on parle
français on est capable d'apporter une
richesse à l'activité économique de ce
jour mon collègue du monde rappelait
c'est 35000 35000 litres de séjour
délivré mais là c'est les gars mais
quand on est fini juste simplement d'une
phrase c'est que moi quand je dis
l'interview de Monsieur Darmanin ce
matin lui il nous dit on va régulariser
des gens qui devraient être expulsés en
fait qui sont clandestins qui n'ont rien
à faire sur le territoire national et
qu'il ne devrait même pas tous les avoir
le droit
national on est dans un chalet vous avez
des gens qui rencontrer légalement et
qui deviennent illégales pour plein de
raisons parce qu'aujourd'hui cette
chaîne là est défaillante voilà c'est ça
le sujet c'est ça le sujet et ça devient
des hôpitaux qui parlent très bien
français qui qui ont un métier et je les
ai soutenu et nous le faisons tous et
vous allez trouver des histoires et j'en
connais aussi mais là on parle de flux
de centaines de milliers de personnes de
centaines de milliers de personnes
avec une question est-ce que c'est pas
un peu hypocrite parce que ça existe
déjà circulaire Manuel Valls si vous
avez un logement si vous avez 24 mois de
travail continuez des notions de
français vous pouvez déjà être
régularisé et d'ailleurs l'employeur
doit aller à la préfecture aujourd'hui
pour accompagner son son travailleur
nous ce qu'on veut c'est que l'employé
puisse aussi faire la démarche et ça
c'est nouveau parce que vous dites que
l'employeur a intérêt à garder une
personne sans papier c'est ça l'idée
donc l'employé travailleur étranger seul
peut aller à la préfecture avec cette
avec cette nouvelle mesure est-ce que
c'est une bonne chose ou pas mais c'est
une bonne chose mais il faut bien
comprendre ce qui se passe en préfecture
la difficulté aujourd'hui c'est quoi en
particulier sur les travailleurs qui
sont intégrés qui sont là puis-je
reconnu depuis 15 20 25 ans qui ont des
titres de séjour de 10 ans pour
travailler et en fait les guichets de la
préfecture sont tellement occupés
tellement pris d'assaut sur les
rendez-vous par internet que aujourd'hui
il pourra ne serait-ce pour avoir un
rendez-vous il faut consulter un avocat
pour faire débloquer au niveau de la
préfecture des rendez-vous pour faire
renouveler un titre de séjour donc nous
ce qu'on proposer au niveau des
républicains ça en effet diminuer les
procédures pour dégager du temps pour
les agents des préfectures afin de faire
en sorte qu'ils puissent recevoir tout
le monde et en fait on a des personnes
qui sont légalement présentes en France
qui ont un travail qui ont des familles
qui ont des enfants qui ont parfois des
petits enfants qui ont un CDI qui sont
parfaitement légalement en France depuis
des dizaines d'années et qui tout d'un
coup parce que on peut pas renouveler un
titre de séjour dans les 9 mois
précédents
j'ai toujours dit et que du coup et que
du coup c'est son ces personnes là pour
certaines pas toutes qui basculent dans
la clandestinité non pas parce qu'elles
l'ont voulu mais parce qu'elles n'ont
pas pu matériellement faire une demande
de renouvellement un titre de séjour
c'est un chiffre du rapport du Sénat
déjà alors qu'il y a juste des notions
françaises un peu plus ça va dans le bon
sens et c'est bien pour ça que nous on
se pose une question comme ça existe
déjà pourquoi faire cette annonce à part
massivement régularisé tous ceux qui ne
sont pas dans le cas que je viens
d'expliquer mais qui sont arrivés par
exemple avec un visa étudiant avec un
visa vie privée familiale et qui du coup
basculer dans des trappes à bas salaire
comme je les ai tout à l'heure parce que
la réalité c'est quoi c'est qu'en France
on a une immigration familiale subit à
faible qualification contrairement à
tous les pays de l'OCDE qui ont une
immigration de travail choisie sur
qualifier pour notamment l'hôpital où il
y a déjà beaucoup de médecins étrangers
un peu évoqué mais on va tirer tout le
monde vers le bas on va être extrêmement
concret vous avez un restaurateur
pourquoi il y a une pénurie vous allez
demander à une jeune fille qui avait 21
ans d'être serveuse a fini son service à
23h30 minuit elle a pas les moyens
d'habiter en centre-ville donc elle va
prendre un transport en commun le RER en
région parisienne des trains régionaux
en province une demi-heure trois quarts
d'heure à Valras craindre pour sa
sécurité elle va pas accepter le job
donc on va aller chercher des gens qui
vont accepter pour des conditions qui ne
sont pas dignes de la 6e puis se balade
nous sommes en 2022
même par l'homme c'est la vision Macron
maintenant vous êtes pour la régression
sociale
mais ne cotise pas à la sécurité sociale
vous leur donnez des papiers il cotise
ça apporte à l'économie française ça
apporte au compte socio français tout
est bénéfique dans cette affaire le seul
problème c'est de savoir si oui ou non
on accepte effectivement que des gens
qui viennent d'ailleurs puissent trouver
leur vie et leur place en France pour
moi la réponse est un grand oui voilà
oui j'entends ici côté du Pesse oui mais
côté LR non trois fois non avec des
arguments très sociaux qui peuvent
surprendre
non mais l'aspect social on tire la
société française
c'est pas gagné on le sent bien sans les
républicains très clairement et un petit
groupe qui s'appelle liotte qui est
centre droit plutôt centre se passe
entre gauche centre ça passe pas donc
jusqu'où vous êtes prêts à demander
là-dessus discuter le débat il l'a dit
plusieurs fois il est prêt à discuter
amender son texte voilà bien donc non
mais attendez tout à l'heure quand vous
faites des propositions du style on va
couper tout transfert d'argent vers les
pays d'origine bah oui
on va refaire ce débat tiens c'est comme
par hasard après le congrès des
républicains peut-être qu'on trouvera
davantage de base d'accord merci
messieurs merci beaucoup d'être venu
débattre franchement sur ce plateau on
va présent accueillir notre grand témoin
il a eu un rôle important dans la
gestion de la crise sanitaire dans l'une
des régions les plus touchées
l'Île-de-France dans la blessure et le
rebond chez Odile Jacob il raconte sans
fard les coulisses d'une crise où il
devra tout à la fois trouver des livres
réanimation décider des évacuations
encore organiser le plan de vaccination
j'étais une sorte de général chargée de
tenir un des fronts du conflit écrit-il
dans ce récit à la fois personnel sur le
rôle et les moyens de l'État au pareil
circonstances Aurélien Rousseau nous
rejoint juste après l'invitation signée
ce soir Stéphanie Despierres
si on vous invite Aurélien Rousseau
c'est parce que vous avez été aux
avant-postes de l'épidémie de covid et
que vous en avez fait un livre
aujourd'hui vous êtes le bras droit de
la première ministre à Matignon mais
lorsque la pandémie déferle vous êtes
directeur de l'agence régionale de santé
d'Île-de-France votre administration
chapeau de plus de 300 hôpitaux
historiens de formation vous avez voulu
écrire pour contrer la vitesse
fulgurante de l'oubli vous raconter la
peur qui vous prend au ventre et ne vous
lâche plus des mars 2020 cette course
contre la montre pour trouver des livres
réanimation du personnel des
respirateurs déployer des tests créer
des centres de vaccination vous défendez
les fonctionnaires qui forment cette
ligne invisible du service public dans
la bataille contre le virus ce que vous
retenez de cette crise c'est qu'elle a
été marquée plus encore que d'autres du
saut de l'incertitude c'est pas parce
qu'on ne sait pas on doit arrêter d'agir
et on doit prendre des décisions dans
l'incertitude et je pense qu'il y a une
forme de nouveau contrats démocratique à
passer avec avec les citoyens qui
consistent à dire ben on vous présente
les alternatives d'une certaine manière
c'est ça le débat démocratique on a fait
un choix et on va peut-être faire des
erreurs donc il faut aussi que je me
mets évidemment dans le Lot les les
responsables publics au sens large on
apprenne à dire ben là je me suis planté
si vous faites votre d'humilité et
prenez la transparence vous fustigez
aussi ceux qui veulent réécrire la
chronologie de l'épidémie à l'aune des
connaissances d'aujourd'hui votre livre
paraît alors que la justice enquête sur
la responsabilité des politiques et de
l'état mi-octobre l'ancien Premier
ministre Edouard Philippe a été entendu
par la Cour de Justice de la République
pour sa gestion de la crise et il s'est
défendu aucun pays n'a tout bien fait je
vais vous dire aucun responsable
politique ne peut dire regardez j'ai
tout bien fait c'est pas du tout ça que
je dis ce que je dis c'est que ni pour
Agnès Buzyn ni pour Olivier ni pour moi
ni pour aucun des collaborateurs qui ont
travaillé avec nous il y a d'infraction
de caractères pénal et c'est ce que je
veux démontrer alors Aurélien Rousseau
au vu de ce que vous avez appris et
compris de cette épidémie dites-nous au
risque de grossir un peu le trait que
faut-il changer au sein de l'État pour
être prêt pour la prochaine crise
bonsoir Aurélien Rousseau et merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour pour évoquer ce livre la
blessure et le rebond votre temps est
compté vous êtes aujourd'hui directeur
de cabinet d'Elisabeth borne à Matignon
mais vous étiez donc le patron de l'ARS
l'agence régionale de santé
Île-de-France on va commencer par le
rebond tiens pour parler de la blessure
peut-être un peu après c'est la c'est la
fin du livre pour répondre à la question
qui qui vous est posée vous défendez
beaucoup d'État dans ce livre et tous
ces fonctionnaires mais c'est aussi un
livre qui veut regarder dans la boîte
noire de l'État il y a eu des
défaillances d'ailleurs vous l'assumez
s'il y avait une chose à faire
à changer dans ce qui n'a pas marché
dans ce qui n'a pas fonctionné au sein
de l'État pendant cette crise ce serait
quoi
c'est difficile à dire parce que c'est
d'avoir une crise qui dure depuis très
longtemps elle n'est pas elle n'est pas
finie et je pense que ce qui a
fonctionné donc peut-être qu'on aurait
dû collectivement mettre en oeuvre
plutôt c'est l'exercice de transparence
c'est le fait de dire on ne sait pas
c'est le fait de dire l'incertitude
parce que parce qu'en fait c'est une
crise ou paradoxalement il y avait
beaucoup de sachant qui était
quelquefois y compris du côté du corps
médical et en fait on était quand même
dans quelque chose de totalement inédit
peut-être qu'on n'a pas su dire à quel
point on était dans l'inédit et à quel
point il allait falloir qu'on réinvente
notre manière de faire il y avait pas
l'état qui savait où il fallait aller il
fallait qu'on construise ce que dans la
blessure et le rebond j'appelle des
coalitions avec les collectivités avec
les associations et ça
un processus délibératif collectif
d'actions à tous les échelons et pas
forcément d'ailleurs que public parce
que vous dites que l'intérêt général
n'est pas forcément le monopole de
l'État ça peut être aussi le privé on
l'a vu d'ailleurs dans la grande
distribution sur les masques on l'a vu
dans au niveau des au niveau des
collectivités locales on sent que vous
défendez l'état on sent que vous voulez
changer la méthode accepter l'humilité
peut-être savoir dire on ne sait pas
mais vous refuriez tout pareil ou pas
alors c'est peut-être l'ancien prof
d'histoire qui sommeille en moi vous
vous étiez dedans vous n'êtes pas un de
ces donneurs de le soit postériori après
moi je me méfie toujours de de
l'anachronisme
pêcher péché capital pour pour
l'historien je me je me dis que sans
doute des choses qu'on a mieux faites en
deuxième en troisième en quatrième vague
si s'il en avait su on l'aurait fait
différemment je pense par exemple que
la coopération entre la médecine de
ville et l'hôpital on l'aurait on
l'aurait poussé plus fort plus vite mais
plus rapidement et puis on avait mais on
avait aussi à l'époque si on se remet
des tellement d'incertitudes par exemple
on avait peur que les salles d'attente
des médecins deviennent des foyers de
contamination si les gens y aller bon
ben finalement en organisant
différemment des flux
séparés on pouvait on pouvait faire ça
mais c'est aussi le fait d'avoir tâtonné
il faut assumer le mot qui nous a permis
d'être plus efficace en deuxième année
la transparence c'est aussi dire la
vérité ces masques ça a été très
important puisque voilà les
collectivités ont dit voilà on prend on
prend le dossier en main ça a été pareil
par rapport à certains certains privés
c'est aussi dire voilà la réalité des
choses pas seulement on sait pas mais
dire la réalité de quelque chose qui
n'est pas forcément acceptable dans
l'instant est-ce qu'il faut tout dire
dans ces moments-là
c'est très difficile moi je suis dans le
livre je ne suis pas là pour pour donner
des leçons c'est pas un manuel de survie
pour fonctionner embarquer dans une
crise
et de la prévention pour l'avenir
beaucoup c'est vrai j'affirme quelques
quelques convictions et puis je pense
que c'est aussi l'état d'esprit d'une
maison comme on dit le Jacob qui
m'accueille dans ses collections mais là
c'est sûr que je pense vous citiez les
masques que au fond ce qui s'est produit
si on le décompose c'est malheureusement
on a créé de la suspicion là où on avait
rien voulu cacher et pour le coup on a
dit enfin moi je m’entends le dire je me
ré-entends le dire on va prioriser les
soignants parce que c'est ceux qui sont
au plus proche et le plus en risque et
dans le même temps beaucoup de
scientifiques disaient il y a pas besoin
de masque dans l'espace public etc et on
a dit ça mais les données scientifiques
ont bougé ont et à ce moment là
peut-être c'est là que je le dis
peut-être qu'on aurait dû formuler
différemment le fait que quelque chose
qu'on pensait juste quelques jours avant
s'avérer
s'avérer il faut mais l'opinion publique
aussi change décembre
2020 tout le monde est tétanisé à l'idée
que les Français pourraient refuser les
vaccins avec un ARN messager et puis au
final c'est ce vaccin qui le plébiscite
et voilà donc c'est pas pour refaire la
question des masques le procédé masque
la réalité maintenant on la connaît les
stocks avaient été détruits ce qui est
intéressant c'est aussi ce que ce que
vous racontez de ce qui a changé dans la
crise toutes ces énergies qui a fait que
collectivement on a su répondre
notamment à l'hôpital avec plus de
rapidité dans la décision est-ce que
vous pensez que la chaîne de
commandement va changer à l'hôpital
l'organisation on a beaucoup dit que ça
avait marché aussi parce que les
médecins avaient repris le pouvoir
est-ce que l'hôpital de demain post
crise saura sera tirer les leçons moi je
pense que évidemment qu'il qu'il doit et
qu'il saura tirer les leçons je pense
que il y a beaucoup moins que que ce
qu'on le dit parfois d'opposition entre
le directeur d'hôpital et les médecins
mais c'est sûr que face à la crise on
avait un objectif qui était le même et
que il y a des verrous
administratifs du quotidien qu'on a fait
sauter parce que le il y avait un compte
à rebours permanent et du coup c'est
certain que de ce point de vue là alors
que et encore aujourd'hui encore des
malades hospitalisés il y a tous les
jours des gens qui meurent du covid mais
ça a donné le sentiment est-ce qu'on
peut paradoxal que c'était allégé et
qu'on allait tous dans le même sens et
ça c'est extrêmement précieux parce que
ça redonne du sens aussi à ce qu'on fait
un soignant il est là pour soigner il
est pas là pour être héro il est là pour
faire son métier avec les moyens
nécessaires et je pense que ça c'était
ça fait partie des éléments du rebond il
faut qu'on garde ça comme un peu une une
pépite et qu'on arrive à le faire
fructifier parce que vous prenez la
plume de façon sensible vous dites je et
vous racontez ce que vous avez traversé
ça a été difficile on va on va en parler
c'est la blessure mais le rebond
toujours vous dites l'Île-de-France a
été une des régions les plus touchées
par le covid les gens sont morts d'être
pauvres c'est votre phrase vous parlez
de repositionner le rôle du système de
soins dans la vers la réduction des
inégalités qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
concrètement ça veut dire que
quand le 20 mars 2020 je reçois les
premières études sur la surmortalité
sous les yeux je vois que le département
qui est le plus jeune d'Île-de-France et
celui où il y a le plus de morts et
d'abord c'est la sidération on se
demande si les chiffres sont faux parce
que le voilà la Seine-Saint-Denis le
covid normalement toucher les personnes
les plus âgées et puis deuxième question
que je me pose pour être très direct
c'est est-ce qu'on soigne moins bien
enseigné est-ce que les il y a eu plus
de morts à cause de ça non on fait
toutes les comparaisons et en fait on
s'aperçoit que les gens sont morts
d'avoir d'autres pathologies des
pathologies qui sont souvent liées à la
précarité aux inégalités sociales
notamment l'obésité et donc aujourd'hui
quand dans ces jours-là dans ces dans
ces soirées-là quand on visitait des réa
ce qui était frappant ce que les les
soignants racontés c'était beaucoup de
gens effectivement en surpoids qui
étaient plus dur à tourner à mettre en
décubitus ventrale et donc ça c'est
le rebond mais c'était d'abord c'était
d'abord une une sacrée blessure et ce
que j'ai voulu dire un peu c'est vrai
sous forme de conviction très forte
c'est que on avait en France un système
de soins qui était exceptionnel mais
qu'on devait aussi acquérir cette
culture de la prévention qu'on a sans
doute beaucoup moins qu'ailleurs oui
les conditions de logement sont des
déterminants essentiels de santé oui
évidemment la façon dont on se nourrit
est indéterminant essentiel de santé et
tout ça quand on superpose d'acquérir
une culture de la prévention et combien
il faut mettre de moyens pour changer ça
il y a des pays qui qui l'ont fait
depuis longtemps le Canada par exemple
avec notamment ceux qui ce qu'on appelle
la médecine communautaire c'est-à-dire y
compris d'adapter en fonction des
risques qu'on identifie dans les
différentes cibles de la population je
pense que ça peut prendre des années
mais je pense qu'il faut une résolution
une détermination politique sans faille
parce que c'est pas on le voit pas à
très court terme mais par exemple si on
arrive à avoir et à mettre autant
d'intelligence que ce qu'on met
d'intelligence pour résoudre certaines
pour retrouver des des traitements à des
maladies complexes sur mais autant
d'intelligence en santé publique on va
évidemment faire que moins de gens
tomberont malade à l'été 2021 vous
quittez éreinter votre poste sans regret
mais hanté par la mélancolie alors c'est
rare pourra au fonctionnaires comme vous
d'assumer ses faiblesses vous avez une
dépression après la crise pourquoi vous
avez choisi de le dire
parce que je crois que au fond d'abord
c'était pas comment dirais je n'ai pas
vraiment choisi d'une certaine manière
ça c'est imposé avec l'idée de dire que
ce qui peut apparaître quelques fois
comme une fragilité en fait c'est une
c'est un des éléments de la force de la
même manière je fais le parallèle dire
qu'on ne sait pas ça peut apparaître une
fragilité mais dans le long terme c'est
une force et moi je pensais à tous ceux
qui moins exposés que moi moins entouré
que moi des soignants des personnels des
ARS des personnels administratifs des
hôpitaux avaient peut-être vécu la même
chose et je me suis dit ça vaut la peine
de dire que ça arrive et que et que le
rebond le trouve voilà de votre récit
qu'il est sensible qu'il est passionnant
et qu'il est intime en plus d'être très
politique merci beaucoup Aurélien
Rousseau le cerveau gauche d'Elisabeth
borne vous vous souvenez c'est un titre
il y a quelques semaines du journal de
monde ça vous va
je pense que Elizabeth borne n'a pas
besoin d'avoir un cerveau de plus et que
de ce point de vue là la ligne et le
dépassement est très clair en elle sur
la plupart des sujets merci beaucoup le
devoir de réserve n'est pas très loin
merci à vous merci beaucoup Aurélien
Rousseau la blessure et le rebond c'est
à dire chez Odile Jacob on va accueillir
à présent nos affranchis pour leur parti
pris ce soir l'économie avec Fanny
guinochet la France championne des
impôts malgré les baisses annoncées le
regard européen de Richard Berly le
nouveau président brésilien Lula est-il
forcément le meilleur allié de l'Europe
et ben on verra ça et puis la mise au
point d'Isabelle Lasserre sur la guerre
ce soir la Crimée péninsule sous tension
nous affranchis les voici bonsoir à vous
trois Fanny on commence avec vous
l'édito Eco sur France Info un petit peu
de pub ne fait jamais de mal mais
chroniqueuse également dans cette
émission vous vouliez revenir sur les
baisses d'impôts alors c'est le Light
motiv le mantra du gouvernement la
baisse des impôts de production pour les
entreprises notamment la France garde
malgré ça sont tristes records
championne de la pression fiscale au
sein de la zone euro effectivement c'est
ce que montre une étude un classement de
FIP Eco FIP Eco c'est un site
d'information sur les finances publiques
le taux de prélèvement obligatoire en
français s'élève à 45 47 % du PIB du PIB
c'est à dire la richesse créée alors
dans prélèvement obligatoire il faut
compter à la fois les cotisations
sociales et puis les impôts et ce 47% il
s'applique aussi bien aux entreprises
qu'au ménage c'est une moyenne alors
c'est quand même 5 points de plus que la
moyenne de la zone euro c'est mieux
qu'avant quand on regarde les années
précédentes c'est surtout parce que les
autres ont un peu augmenté leurs impôts
dans les autres pays donc l'écart se
resserre mais le problème c'est que même
si ça s'améliore les impôts c'est un peu
comme la météo il y a le la réalité et
le ressenti que les Français ne s'en
rendent pas compte et bien non ils sont
encore l'impression de beaucoup payer
alors certes je viens de vous dire qu'il
paye déjà beaucoup mais ils peuvent
aussi avoir un petit peu l'impression en
ce moment que l'État leur reprend une
main ce qui leur donne de l'autre je
prends un exemple tout simple la taxe
d'habitation elle est en passe d'être
supprimée encore 20% de français la paye
c'est ce sont les plus riches alors
certes elle est supprimée mais de
l'autre côté on voit les taxes foncières
alors c'est pour les propriétaires mais
qui elles flambe et puis ça n'est pas de
chance mais les baisses d'impôts sont
aussi complètement engloutis par
l'inflation à cinq pas de chance pour le
gouvernement évidemment mais avec des
prix qui augmentent des salaires qui
sont revalorisés mais pas à la même
hauteur et bien les ménages forcément
ces mécaniques voire leur niveau de vie
se dégrader que fait l'état d'ailleurs
de tous ces impôts est-ce que c'est
fléchés est-ce qu'on le sait alors c'est
justement la question est même le
problème parce que il paye et
parallèlement il se rendent compte que
leur service public sont dégradés alors
c'est dommage que Aurélien rousse vous
en avez ne soit pas là avec nous on en a
vous en avez parlé avec lui mais c'est
vrai que quand vous prenez l'hôpital il
y a eu la crise covid on s'est dit on va
mettre de l'argent sur l'hôpital les
impôts mais on voit que la première
épidémie de bronchiolite et bien
l'hôpital craque autre exemple très
concret les écoles certes le
gouvernement fait des efforts en nous
disant on va essayer de mettre un
professeur devant chaque élève enfin
devant chaque classe et on voit bien
qu'il y a des manques les exemples il y
en a plein vous prenez les trains 11000
TER supprimer dans la seule région des
Hauts de France cette année donc vous
imaginez les gens qui ne n'ont que ce
moyen de transport il se retrouve bien
en peine et c'est vrai que cette liste
qui est très longue qui s'alourdie elle
donne quel sentiment celui du
déclassement et elle contribue aussi à
instiller une suspicion de la part des
usagers en disant mais où va cet argent
et pour reprendre une expression
qu'Emmanuel Macron avait lui-même
utilisé mais où passe ce pognon de
dingue merci
[Musique]
un adversaire le Brésil de bolsonaro
c'est-à-dire le président sortant a
refusé de voter aux côtés des Européens
et des Occidentaux contre la Russie il
refuse d'appliquer les sanctions donc
aujourd'hui les entreprises russes
peuvent continuer de commercer
normalement avec le Brésil et surtout
n'oublions pas du côté européen que Lola
est un vétéran de la gauche
latino-américaine et il y a un diable
qui existe c'est l'oncle Sam Lola il
n'aime pas les ingérences des États-Unis
il a quand même des raisons historiques
de son méfier il est vrai sauf qu'il y a
d'autres présidents de gauche
aujourd'hui en Amérique latine qui sont
d'accord avec lui il y a un président de
gauche je le rappelle au Chili en
Colombie au Mexique bref la lune de miel
qu'on dont on rêve avec le Brésil elle
sera peut-être climatique mais elle ne
sera sûrement pas géopolitique ça veut
dire que Lula pourrait carrément aller
jusqu'à soutenir Poutine alors soutenir
Poutine sûrement pas mais par contre
à partir du moment où il sera au pouvoir
Lula il va vouloir camper un
positionnement qui est celui des non
alignés et on va en avoir un avant alors
ce sera pas lu là ce sera bolsonaro qui
sera présent à la mi-novembre au sommet
du G20 à Bali en Indonésie et à ce
moment-là on risque de voir un Brésil
qui ne va pas du tout être du côté des
Occidentaux et ça il faudra le suivre
Lola ensuite il entrera en fonction et
Luna il a un autre objectif il veut
aussi quand même montrer à l'électorat
montrer au Brésilien qu'ils ont eu
raison de voter pour lui pour ça il va
essayer de solidariser autour de lui les
pays du Sud le fameux global South dont
on voit qu'il pose quelques problèmes à
l'Europe d'autant qu'il y a un accord
commercial que le Brésil veut c'est
l'accord sur le Mercosur que l'Union
européenne n'a toujours pas ratifié même
si elle a signé et pourquoi elle ne l'a
pas ratifié je vous le donne en mille
c'est notamment parce que la France s'y
oppose et on espère que ça se dénouera
en 2023 donc avec Lula il va falloir
certes se méfier mais il va falloir
aussi se dire que peut-être on pourrait
avoir des surprises l'avertissement de
Richard Werly Isabelle vouliez revenir
sur la Crimée il y a une attaque de
contre le port de Sébastopol occupé par
les Russes samedi dernier est-ce que ça
veut dire que les Ukrainiens ont
l'intention de récupérer la Crimée
Myriam en théorie sans doute oui parce
que même si les frappes russes n'ont pas
fait des dégâts énormes les frappent
ukrainiennes pardon n'ont pas fait des
dégâts énormes contre les navires russes
le symbole est fort c'est la deuxième
fois en un mois que les Ukrainiens
attaquent la Crimée souvenez-vous le
mois dernier point ils ont oui ils ont
frappé le fameux pont qui relie la
péninsule à la Russie alors au tout
début de la guerre le président
ukrainien voit le dîmes zenenski s'était
dit ouvert à d'éventuelles négociations
avec la Russie il avait même envisagé il
était envisagé une espèce de de statue
particulier pour la Crimée qui serait de
de geler son statut pendant plusieurs
années vous savez c'était le modèle de
Hong Kong mais depuis il y a eu bout de
chat les crimes de guerre commis par les
forces russes il y a eu la
radicalisation l'escalade de Vlad et
puis aussi oui et puis aussi les succès
de la contre-offensive ukrainienne donc
aujourd'hui Vladimir Zelenski a changé
d'avis sa position est claire récupérée
tous les territoires occupés crimés
compris et d'ailleurs le président
ukrainien a signé un décret le mois
dernier qui interdit à l'Ukraine de
négocier avec la Russie tant qu'elle est
gouvernée par vous dire Poutine les
Ukrainiens sur le plan militaire ils ont
les moyens de cette récupération d'un
territoire qui est le leur alors là il y
a eu 2014 là encore en théorie non en
tout cas pas pour l'instant la Crimée
c'est un bout beaucoup plus gros et
beaucoup plus difficile que le don basse
une partie de la population il est
toujours favorable au Russe Sébastopol
habite encore abrite encore une partie
de la de la flotte de la mer Noire de
nombreux missiles ils sont installés et
pour la Crimée et pour le Kremlin la
Crimée est une zone stratégique qui
débloque l'accès à la Méditerranée en
2014 quand Vladimir Poutine annexer la
péninsule sont sa popularité avait été
dopée s'il perd la Crimée aujourd'hui il
perd la guerre et donc il perd le
pouvoir Moscou fera absolument tout pour
l'empêcher et nous les Européens les
Occidentaux est-ce qu'on laisse comme ça
voler des Hélène ski avoir des visées
sur la Crimée ou pas alors ça c'est
toute la question parce que même si
l'armée
ukrainienne est devenu tellement aguerri
que certains la présentent aujourd'hui
comme une des meilleures d'Europe la
victoire de l'Ukraine en Crimée comme
dans le bon basse dépend aujourd'hui de
l'aide militaire américaine aura
Washington comme d'ailleurs à Berlin et
à Paris dévoit ses lèvres pour dire à
volo diverselenski ne soit pas trop
gourmand et pour demander à l'Ukraine de
se contenter de se limiter en fait au
territoire qui ont été pris après le 24
février 2022 tout ça bien entendu pour
ne pas énerver comme on dit Vladimir
Poutine Vladimir Poutine en 2015 avait
déjà
affirmer que il aurait utilisé l'arme
nucléaire pour sécuriser l'annexion de
la Crimée si jamais les occidentaux
avaient voulu l'en empêcher donc à bon
entendeur salut reste à savoir
aujourd'hui si les Ukrainiens vont
suivre les conseils de leur mentor
américain on verra ça la ligne rouge
c'est la table contre la Russie là ce
serait une grosse ligne rouge mais pour
l'instant on incite si je comprends bien
le problème c'est que aller jusqu'au la
Russie la Crimée
récupérer la crise quand même c'est que
la dynamique militaire semble plutôt
inférieure de l'Ukraine mais quand on
regarde l'espace de terrain reconquis ça
reste quand même assez limité et donc
on voit que cette armée ukrainienne
quand même patine me semble-t-il et le
temps joue malheureusement en faveur
plutôt de Poutine en tout cas 10
secondes à l'aise dans toute l'est de
l'Europe on considère qu'il ne peut y
avoir qu'une victoire absolument totale
et que la victoire en plus sera totale
quand Vladimir le régime Vladimir
Poutine ce sera effondré merci les
affranchis merci pour vos regards
respectifs l'économie famille guinochet
de France Info Isabelle laferre des
pages diplômes du Figaro bien sûr pour
l'international Richard Berly l'Europe
pour le site quotidien suisse Blic merci
à vous c'est la fin de cette émission
très belle soirée sur LCP bien sûr et à
demain
[Musique]